balance is an overlooked aspect of human
performance yet it is integral to the
ability to move powerfully and with
confidence balance is not only crucial
to ensure you remain steady on your feet
it's also critical for generating power
traversing the environment and moving
with Grace and Poise you might not think
about it this way we're actually
balancing all the time you're balancing
right now you might think that you're
static right now but you're actually in
motion all the time as Tiny muscles in
your body contract and release tension
in order to maintain that Center of
balance and prevent you from falling
forwards even if you're sitting down
you're balancing your upper body so you
don't plummet and smack your face onto
the keyboard your body is in constant
communication and conflict with gravity
but how do we train balance
first we must Define it a great visual
analogy I've heard is to imagine an
equilateral triangle place the triangle
on its bottom and it will remain steady
this is stability but flip it over and
stand it perfectly on its peak and this
is balance newsflash you are not a
triangle so how does this apply to you
essentially the less stability you have
the more balance you need and it's
considerably harder to generate power
without stability this is why squatting
weight on a balance board is not a good
way to build muscular strength that's
not to say it's impossible to generate
power while in an unstable position
though just look at the power you can
deliver from one leg with a roundhouse
kick or the ability of a free runner to
LEAP great distances from a narrow beam
balance can then somewhat make up for
stability when it's missing so how does
the body regulate balance
first balance is not completely
explained by the vestibular system
balance is not a sense not really rather
It's a combination of Senses working in
unison your vestibular system provides
your ability to detect changes in the
position of your head as you likely
remember from school biology lessons
this works by a fluid contained within
three semi-circular canals alongside the
utricle and saccule in the ear butrical
and saccule the otolith organs detect
gravity and linear motion while the
canals are filled with a fluid called
endolymph which detects rotational
movement as the head moves the fluid
follows and creates pressure against the
sensory receptors of the canals
meanwhile the otolith organs respond to
the movement of tiny calcium carbonate
crystals called otoconia apologies if
I'm butchering some of these terms I
read them I don't tend to hear them the
brain then calculates information from
all these inputs to understand
orientation and movement essentially all
this works in much the same way that the
accelerometer and gyroscope work in your
phone but the Savvy of you might have
already noted the problem rotation and
changes in orientation of the head don't
necessarily mean that your whole body is
changing position this is where
proprioception plays an important role
so proprioception is the sense of your
body in space and this is the result of
multiple different systems once again
the muscle spindles Golgi tendon organs
and pechinian core puscules to name just
a few these detect changes in muscle
length muscular effort and surface
pressure across the body and the fascia
also plays a role here again with its
own mechanoreceptors to detect changes
in pressure between the muscles a great
way to train proprioception during
exercise is to close your eyes so by
closing your eyes or wearing a blindfold
in this case perhaps you have to close
my eyes inside the blindfold because
it's really not that opaque you can
force yourself to focus more on your
body and your sense of proprioception
where each joint is in space and at the
same time listening to that vestibular
system by cutting out Vision you have to
rely more heavily on the other senses
and by practicing this over time you can
get better at tuning in to those senses
of course you need to be really careful
practicing things like calisthenics with
your eyes closed but if you do it in a
safe manner if you've got a soft landing
and use exercises that you're relatively
confident using then closing your eyes
as you start to feel more competent can
increase the challenge and help you to
listen to your body even more something
else to be aware of whilst you're
practicing these calisthenics is keeping
your body loose and releasing tension
because many of the writing mechanisms
in your body I've learned on tiny small
muscles and things like the myotatic
stretch response these are automatic
reflexes that we don't have conscious
control over your body wants to
naturally be in alignment and the way to
allow it to get into that straight and
upright posture that's going to maintain
balance and center of gravity is to
relax and then let your body do its
thing if you tense up and contract
muscles wildly especially when you're
falling if you panic this is actually
when you lose balance if you want to try
a cool trick to see just how aligned you
are when you're balancing try squatting
down on a balance beam or a bar this is
something that Liam showed me and it
just ensures that you really are
maintaining a good Center of balance
through the midfoot as you squat down if
you don't have good Mobility you won't
be able to do this in the handstand for
example all the effort goes out of the
move once you actually find that
equilibrium and stack those joints on
top of each other the same thing goes
for any other position another massive
tip for improving proprioception and
balance is to take off your shoes or
train in minimal Footwear thick soles
and large heels muffle signals that
otherwise come from the feet and provide
crucial information about the shape of
the ground beneath your feet should even
be able to contort and shape themselves
around the ground but over time you'll
also get better at integrating that
information greatly improving your
balance and that brings me to today's
sponsor Vivo Barefoot there's actually a
special sponsorship for me because when
I started making sponsored videos on the
channel Vivo Barefoot was one of the big
companies that I really had my sights on
working with that's because I've been
using and enjoying Viva barefoot shoes
for years now for those not familiar
Vivo barefoot shoes are minimal shoes
they utilize a wide toe box to allow the
toes to splay as they naturally should a
thin Soul meanwhile lets you feel the
ground beneath your feet and the light
material bends and contorts just as your
foot is designed to do when I first put
on a pair of vivos I immediately noticed
a tremendous difference balancing along
beams in the park balancing in regular
shoes essentially means balancing on a
hard flat slab that is itself balanced
on the bar or trunk or whatever else
with barefoot shoes you can almost grip
the bar by wrapping your feet around it
you stick to it and I can pull off moves
this way that I never could without them
it's just one reason I honestly don't
think I could ever go back to regular
shoes and I especially like the brand
Vivo Barefoot for a few reasons there's
the quality they last a really long time
some of my shoes blasted over two years
and that's with daily use they also look
really good you can wear them out and
about without feeling too strange and
then you can wear them all the way into
the gym a lot of them fit both scenarios
which is really cool and they're
ethically made which to me is a
excellent bonus so yeah guys I really do
like the Verve barefoot shoes you've
seen me wearing them for years in these
videos if you want to give them a try
yourself you can use the code by owner
15 and the link in the description down
below and you'll get 15 off your order
anyways on with the show
what's less proven is the usefulness of
training with balance boards for your
ankles it can be useful for those
rehabilitating from injury but most of
us won't benefit from this to a large
degree at least according to the studies
and the reason for this is that most of
us already have sufficient
proprioception in our ankles so we're
not going to gain a whole load from
practicing balance boards that is not
however to say that you can't benefit at
all from training your ankles in this
way for example trail running has been
shown in study to be very effective and
even better is slack lining slacklining
is fantastic for all kinds of things
improving your proprioception your body
awareness your balance explicitly even
improving things like running speed and
jumping height slack lining is actually
really underrated as a performance
enhancing tool it just goes to show I
think that using something like a
balance board is not mistaken in itself
it's not the fact that challenge is
somewhat two-dimensional and actually
probably too easy for most people but as
we're isolating aspects of
proprioception to focus on another key
one is the neck so we talked earlier
about how your head moving position
doesn't necessarily correlate to your
body moving position so the key area to
focus on here is the neck because your
neck is essentially what is going to
write your head so that it remains
steady whilst your body moves or vice
versa when you run and jump It's the
roll of your neck to keep the head and
even the eyes steady so they don't move
more than necessary if you've ever tried
running and filming without
stabilization on your camera you'll know
just how impossible it is to see what's
going on as such when you begin moving
the brain stem will transmit impulses to
the muscles the control eye movement
head and neck movement as well as many
more muscles throughout the body the
vestibulo ocular reflex or Vore sends
impulses to the eyes and helps to keep
them entirely steady even as the head
moves around this is called eye head
coupling and in fact contractions in
your neck can trigger involuntary eye
movements you can actually test and
experience this connection yourself
because it does work both ways so if you
stand up nice and straight with your
head up straight as well put one hand on
the back of your neck and then move your
eyes and you'll feel little muscles
twitching in the back of your neck these
are your splenius capitae and this is
because of eye head coupling basically
when you're eye moves Direction your
head is readying itself to move
direction as well and so ingrained is
this connection it works both ways that
you actually feel those muscles contract
when Landing from a jump or running
stability is created in the neck through
tension in order to prevent Whiplash or
jolting this both protects the neck and
maintains balance and awareness of an
individual's surroundings I recommend
both training neck strength with either
isometric exercises or light to work
with a plate and neck mobility and
flexibility using neck stretches to keep
the neck limber and responsive
and what's really useful to think about
here as well is looking for movements
that will help you to integrate
proprioception from these different
parts of the body in particular this is
what makes the Hindu push-up so useful
because you're doing this dive bomber
movement with your head and your neck
you're Awakening that vestibular system
and you're already integrating that with
movement throughout your body but then
there's the issue of the unstable
surface it could be that the entire body
is steady but the ground has shifted so
if you're fighting on a boat in a storm
that happens to people right this is
again where the vestibular system comes
into play but also Vision plays a role
here and this is why watching The
Horizon can be so useful to keep the
body upright it's also a matter of
learning what visual feedback you should
be looking for during a successful
movement and then adjusting in
accordance with that when performing a
flip of any kind for the first time your
brain will be confused and alarmed at
the world's spinning around it when
performing one for the thousandth time
it'll be used to that input and thus
better able to marry the information
coming from the various senses in this
case practice this makes perfect and
learning how to spot and where to look
during movements is a crucial aspect of
performance and the more different
movements you add to your Arsenal the
better you'll become at dealing with
unexpected orientations well not
everyone is going to start tricking like
Grant what you can do is to incorporate
some more variation in your movement
most people can start learning to
cartwheel or practicing brake Falls and
these will help include a bit of Rapid
rotation and inversion of course I'm
also a big fan of handstands and you can
practice handstands this is another good
way to practice being in a different
position and helping your body to learn
what that feels and looks like
Emmy out the mouth so then in conclusion
what is it that we can start doing right
now to improve our balance and
equilibrium to exceptional standards
start practicing more inversions and
calisthenics that involve balancing on
one leg or on your hands it just makes
sense especially try movements like the
handstand or pistol squat that do
require a lot of proprioception and if
you want to get even more benefit from
this try using a blindfold or just
closing your eyes switch to barefoot
shoes and try trail running to
accelerate your ability to utilize that
information from your feet strengthen
the neck and keep it limber and
neutralize movements like the Hindu
push-up that will help you to integrate
head movement with full body exercise
incorporate trail running and if you
want to go even further then maybe
incorporate slack lining as an
alternative you can maybe try just
balancing along a balance beam and
practice movements like cartwheels and
break Falls these will prepare you for
more rapid changes in orientation so I
hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did please leave
a like and share around that helps me
out immensely and actually the very
biggest thing you guys can do for the
channel right now is to subscribe for
some reason I'm just not gaining
subscribers at the same rate that I had
been in previous months and this is one
of the things I really want to do is
build towards that one million Milestone
so yeah if you guys have been watching
regularly I really would appreciate a
subscribe and do double check if you
think you're already subscribed because
sometimes Google will remove
subscriptions without warning I'd love
to know in the description down below
what you guys do to train your bands do
you do anything at all what have I
missed in this video some of you will be
watching this early on patreon thank you
so much if you're supporting me over on
patreon and for those who aren't aware I
am now starting to upload most not all
of my videos early on patreon with no ad
break as well with no sponsor segment
this one's a bit different because the
Vivo barefoot shoes were so integral to
this video and I probably would have
spoken about them anyways but in general
for the few of you who are currently
watching over on patreon I'll be cutting
out that segment one last piece of
channel news please do keep your eyes
open for scammers in the comments down
below doing my best to tackle it with
software but the best way I think is
just raising Community awareness I made
a YouTube post about this recently so
some of you already know and the
comments on there ended up being
surprisingly hilarious so that was a
good time either way guys thank you so
much for watching this one and I'll see
in the next one
bye for now